Honduras. it's one of
the most dangerous places
in the world to be an
environmental activist.
The case of Berta Cáceres is emblematic,
it's a microcosm of
the situation in Honduras
for many activists and defenders.
Berta Cáceres,
one of the country's most well-known
indigenous environmental leaders,
was gunned down in her home
early Thursday, less than a year
after she won
the prestigious Goldman Environmental Prize.
This particular murder
was particularly brazen.
Someone thought that they
could murder a very, very
prominent person that
they would be able to
get away with that.
This is a story that I had been following
since the actual murder in 2016.
And as I followed it over the years,
the investigation evolved,
it kept taking different twists and turns.
There is no evidence
whatsoever that could link me
to the killing of Berta.
Berta Cáceres was born into
a very political family,
a family of activists, really.
Her mother was one of the first
female mayors in Honduras.
She was the mayor of a
town called La Esperanza.
Berta, she was raised a Catholic.
She was not raised in a
traditionally indigenous household.
But by the time she reached her 20s,
she identified as a Lenca woman.
That's the biggest indigenous
group, native to Honduras.
She co-founded a human rights
organization called COPINH
that was basically for indigenous
communities in Honduras.
And so by her 30s, she
was a national leader.
She was someone who was
extremely passionate
about the rights of the
downtrodden, the marginalized,
the indigenous in her country.
She was also very amiable,
very pleasant, very friendly.
She was good fun.
But behind the laughter and the smiles,
you knew that she had a steely cool.
Angry protestors at the doorsteps of
Honduras's Presidential Palace
want President Manuel Zelaya back.
There was a coup in Honduras in 2009
and the government that took
over really put development
as one of the main
priorities for the country.
And with that came this big building boom.
Honduras does not produce
many natural resources
that can be used for energy.
But one thing that it does
have is a lot of rivers.
So you had a lot of hydroelectric dams
that suddenly were slated for areas
where there was very little development.
One of these companies
that formed at this time
was called DESA and its sole purpose was
to develop the Agua Zarca
dam in Western Honduras.
You had international
development banks funding it
along with private investment in Honduras.
And Berta Cáceres heard
about this project,
knew that there was a Lenca
community that lived nearby,
and she really led an opposition movement.
The residents worried
that the dam project would
flood out the areas that
were critical for them
to grow staples like corn and coffee.
But even more than that, they argued that
the river itself was sacred
and that to dam it in this way
was a violation of Lenca tradition.
No!
Residents began staging protests,
doing things like creating roadblocks.
They would stack stones on the roads
so construction equipment
could not reach the work site.
If you talk to DESA, the
hydro electric company,
they will say that the majority of people
in the communities living around the river
supported the project.
This is a point of contention.
They argue that the community
was in support of the dam
although there were protests and marches
going on at the same time.
No!
DESA decided this is a project
that it would move forward with
without consultation
with local communities.
And there has been just
a tremendous amount
of bloodshed and violence.
On July 15th, 2013,
there was a spontaneous
impromptu rally at the DESA work site.
And this is a date that
everybody on both sides
of this conflict remembers very well.
Tomas García, who was a COPINH protester,
was among a crowd who
entered the DESA work site.
And one of the guards, a security guard,
shot and killed Tomas and shot
and wounded his son, Alan.
Right after the violence
happened, DESA's contractor,
Sinohydro pulled out of the project.
They abandoned the work site
and they never came back.
DESA, instead of abandoning the project,
they actually redesigned it.
So they moved the site of the
dam two kilometers up river,
and they also downsized it
to be what's called a
run of the river project.
So there's less impact to the environment,
but as the protesters contended,
there's not zero impact.
So they had their first
public protest against the dam
in its new location in November of 2015.
And that's when we think
that plans to murder Berta
really began to materialize.
She would tell a lot of her friends
that she would be getting
threats from people at DESA.
You better watch out, watch your back.
She reported cars
following her on the roads.
You know, she would often
look behind her shoulder.
She had people who would
help her with security.
She was definitely scared.
She knew she was at risk.
In 2015, she won the Goldman prize,
which is sometimes called the Green Nobel.
It's really the biggest prize
an environmental activist can get.
And it really kind of pushed her up
into a different level of notoriety.
With hindsight, maybe we could
say that the Goldman prize
put her at greater risk.
It's something that we
need to grapple with this
in the international
human rights community.
Whether we think that
it's a deterrent effect
to be able to raise someone's
profile in the media,
or if that puts them at greater risk.
It's very hard to say.
The prize also came with
$175,000, as a cash award.
And so Berta went back to
Honduras and a lot of that money,
she poured into COPINH,
into new projects and new
facilities in La Esperanza.
In March of 2016, she
had actually put together
a workshop in La Esperanza,
and one of the people who
was speaking at this workshop
was named Gustavo Castro.
He's an environmentalist from Mexico.
He was planning on
staying at another house
with someone else in La Esperanza,
and he went out to visit Berta
and saw how isolated her house was.
This house was located on
the outskirts of La Esperanza
on the far edge of town.
And they started chatting and
she up inviting him to stay
in her guest bedroom.
Gustavo was in his room,
in the guest bedroom,
and Berta was down the hall.
And Gustavo heard a noise in the kitchen.
Before he could even leave
the room to check things out,
he heard the bangs,
there were gunshots
coming from Berta's room.
The gunman apparently thought
that he was dead and left.
And after he heard the
gunman leave the house,
he got up and checked on Berta.
Gustavo searched around for a telephone,
found Berta's phone,
and just started calling
everybody on her contacts.
When he eventually did contact
people, friends of Berta's,
they advised him not to call the police.
I think it's safe to say
that oftentimes the police
were part of the problem,
not part of the solution.
There are terrible stories
of the police hierarchy
being involved in murder-for-hire schemes.
If you called the police,
they may be as likely to shake you down
as they were to help you.
So friends of Berta's helped
get him to another house.
And the police, when they did arrive,
they found his suitcase
in the spare bedroom.
And so the police
identified him as a suspect,
but pretty much everyone
who was close to Berta
simply assumed that
this had something to do
with her opposition to the dam project.
It was a complete shock.
It was a shock, but at the same time,
it wasn't a surprise if that makes sense.
Because of the people that
she was fighting against.
The fact that Berta was killed,
is very clear to us in the
human rights community that
if Berta could be killed with impunity,
any of us could be killed.
I think everyone saw this as a test.
Would Honduras be up to the challenge
of investigating this
murder in a professional way
and taking it wherever it might lead?
Or would this notion of
impunity carry the day?
From the beginning, it
seemed like the police
were wanting to classify
this as a crime of passion.
So they were looking at Gustavo Castro
as a person of interest.
He had been in the house with her.
He's been shot twice.
The Mexican Ambassador tried
to get him out of Honduras.
He's now been taken again
back to La Esperanza
where he was shot and
she was assassinated.
I thought this was a classic
way to try and deflect
from the real perpetrators,
particularly when a woman is the victim
that they think that a crime of passion
is something that people will swallow.
Berta's daughters were really instrumental
in trying to push the police into looking
at the company DESA.
They reached out to other
activists around the world
for people to spread the
word about what had happened.
I'm calling on the Honduran government
to conduct a thorough and
transparent investigation
into the tragic murder of Berta Cáseres.
It doesn't look like they're
going to get justice,
or proper investigations
unless outside protest
really puts pressure on
the Honduran government.
I think a lot of media
attention all over the world,
put pressure on the Honduran
state to act responsibly
and to do a genuine investigation.
Gustavo was finally allowed to leave
and essentially his name was cleared.
And the focus of the investigation
now turned directly towards DESA
The police began analyzing phone data.
So they looked at the cell phone towers
closest to Berta's house
and found the phones
that were active in the area
at the time of the murder.
And so they began putting
the pieces together.
On May 2nd, 2016, police
launched a series of raids
early in the morning,
and they arrested several people that they
alleged were involved in the murder.
And these included alleged hitmen,
Mariano Díaz, who was
accused of being a middleman,
and Douglas Bustillo, who was
a former security chief for DESA.
Really the most important
thing that came of those raids
was what the police were able to collect.
The cell phones of the
people who were arrested.
They were able to retrieve
thousands and thousands
of text messages that became very critical
to reconstruct what
happened in this murder.
I received a call from a colleague
and I was asked to participate
in the investigation.
I was told that the family
didn't trust Honduran authorities,
and that they wanted an independent
investigation of the murder.
The public prosecutor had access to really
a treasure trove of digital data.
And they gave us access
to a small fraction.
And we used that to
identify the parameters
of the murder plot.
So Berta was killed on March 2nd, 2016.
On February 6th, a month before her death,
we can see in the texts,
probably the first
attempt on Berta's life.
This man named Henrry Hernandez is sent
to the town of La
Esperanza, where Berta was.
And he's supposed to be
met there by Mariano Díaz,
an active member of the military.
We know that because Mariano
Díaz's phone had been tapped
because he was being investigated
for involvement in drug trafficking
and the transcripts of
those wiretaps demonstrate
that Mariano Díaz is
gonna get Hernandez a gun.
At the same time, Mariano
Díaz is in conversation with
Douglas Bustillo, former
Head of Security of DESA.
Douglas Bustillo is asking
Mariano Díaz questions like,
have you gotten on the bus?
Are you there yet?
Later Douglas Bustillo
texts David Castillo,
the president of the company, DESA,
and tells him mission aborted.
That mission was abandoned
because Berta was not alone.
Her family was visiting her
and so there wasn't really
an opportunity to execute the plan.
Additionally, when the
investigators were looking into
Douglas Bustillo's phone, they
found images of Berta on it
and also pictures that
he'd taken of her house.
So they believe he was
essentially stalking Berta.
And then later around
the time of the murder,
they saw that Douglas Bustillo
was in contact with the hitmen.
So the investigators were
able to make that link
from the hitmen, through the middleman,
through Douglas Bustillo,
to the executives at DESA
to piece together what they describe as
this long running corporate
conspiracy to try to kill Berta.
And so the investigation
really led to the CEO of DESA,
David Castillo.
So David Castillo was taken
into custody in March of 2018.
I visited Castillo early in 2020,
and he was being held at a military prison
just outside of Tegucigalpa.
And I was able to sit
down with him in his cell
and conduct a couple
of interviews with him.
David Castillo becomes involved in DESA
when he is still a member of the military.
He's integral to establishing,
for founding DESA.
And we were particularly
interested in his background
as a military intelligence officer.
So David essentially says
that the prosecutors have
totally misinterpreted these texts.
That for example, whenever
there was a mission
that was aborted, that they talk about it
being a mission to kill Berta.
He says, no that it was
something completely different
and they've twisted the
meaning to implicate him.
So one of David's main points
is he insists that he and Berta
we're actually good friends.
He has text messages that
his defense has pulled
from his phone between him and Berta.
And many of these messages
do indicate a friendship.
She was very suspicious of
David Castillo and his motives.
That doesn't mean that she
did not regard it as strategic
to have a relationship with him.
What we can also see is
that he is contacting Berta,
having conversations with her,
obtaining information
about her whereabouts
and her activities, and then
funneling that information
to the company executives and employees.
How I interpret this
dynamic is quite typical
of a military intelligence officer.
It's using Berta as human intelligence
to inform how the company
wants to handle opposition
to the dam project.
I think it's fair to say that in Honduras,
people have been able
to get away with murder.
The often quoted statistic is that
only about 3% of murders
in Honduras were solved.
So I think if you had asked
people on that terrible morning,
when Berta Cáceres was murdered,
if they thought that people
would be held to account
for this crime, I think most
people would have said no.
Now the question of course is,
is that the ultimate chain of
command for the murder or not?
So this investigation started
with the hitmen essentially,
the people who pulled the trigger.
It went to David Castillo, the
CEO and that executive level.
And now the Cáceres
family is sort of testing
this concept to see how
far you can extend this.
So now they're going after actually
the investors in the dam project.
I think it's far too easy for investors
to separate themselves from
the impacts of their money,
which is usually in the global south.
It's their money, which is facilitating
and being used to carry out the projects,
which are linked to so many
of these cases of attacks
and killings of activists.
Berta's supporters and her
family came up with a slogan
almost immediately after she was murdered.
And it's translated, Berta
wasn't killed, she multiplied.
That's the message that
they take from this,
that even though her killers
tried to silence her,
her voice is louder now
than it had ever been during her life.